what about
eukaryotic versus prokaryotic cells
prokaryotes
what how big
what are each of those and how big of an
invention is that
i personally think that's the single
biggest invention in the whole history
of life exciting
so what what are they can you explain
yeah so so so i mentioned bacteria and
archaea these are both prokaryotes
um they're basically small cells that
don't have a nucleus if you look at them
under a microscope you don't see much
going on if you look at them under a
super resolution microscope then they're
fantastically complex
in terms of their molecular machinery
they're amazing in terms of their
morphological appearance under a
microscope they're really small
and really simple the earliest life that
we can physically see on the planet are
stromatolites which are made by things
like cyanobacteria and then they're
large superstructures effectively
biofilms plated on top of each other
and and you end up with quite quite
large structures that you can see in the
fossil record
but they they don't
they never came up with animals they
never came out with plants they they
hear with multicellular things
filamentous cyanobacteria for example
they're just long you know strings of
cells
but
the the origin of the eukaryotic cell
seems to have been what's called an
endosymbiosis so one cell gets inside
another cell
and i think that that transformed the
energetic possibilities of life so what
we end up with
is a kind of supercharged cell which can
have a much larger
nucleus with many more genes all
supported
if you think about you could think about
it as multi-bacterial power without the
overhead so you've got it you've got a
cell and it's got bacteria living in it
and those bacteria are providing it with
the energy currency it needs but each
bacterium has a genome of its own which
costs a fair amount of energy to
to express to to kind of turn over and
convert into proteins and so on
what the mitochondria did which are
these
power packs in our own cells they were
bacteria once and they threw away
virtually all their genes they've only
got a few left
so mitochondria is like you said is the
bacteria that got inside a cell
and then throw away all this stuff it
doesn't need to survive inside the cell
and then kept what so what we end up
with so it kept always a handful of
genes
in our own case 37 genes um but there's
there's a few protists which are single
cells things that have got as many as 70
or 80 genes so it's not always the same
but it's always a small number
um and
you can think of it as a paired down
power pack where the control unit is
really being has been uh kind of paired
down to almost nothing so you're putting
out the same power but the the
investment in in the overheads is really
paired down that means that you can
support a much larger nuclear genome so
we've gone up in the number of genes but
also the amount of power you have to
convert those genes into proteins
we've gone up about four-fold in the
number of genes but in terms of the the
size of genomes and your ability to to
make the building blocks make the
proteins we've gone up a hundred
thousand fold or more so it's huge step
change in the possibilities of evolution
uh and it is it's interesting then that
the only the only two occasions that
complex life has arisen on earth plants
and animals
uh fungi you could say are complex as
well but they don't form
such complex morphology as plants and
animals
start with a single cell they start with
an oocyte and a sperm fused together to
make a zygote so you start development
with a single cell and all the cells in
the organism have identical dna and you
switch off in the brain you switch off
these genes and you switch on those
genes and liver you switch off those and
you switch on a different set
and the standard evolutionary
explanation for that is that you've you
you're restricting conflict you don't
have a load of genetically different
cells that are all fighting each other
um and so it works the trouble with
bacteria they form these biofilms and
they're all genetically different and
effectively they're incapable of that
level of cooperation
they would get in a fight
okay so uh why is this such a difficult
invention
of getting this bacteria inside and
becoming an engine
which the mitochondria is why was that
why do you assign it such great
importance is it great importance in
terms of the difficulty of how it was to
achieve a great importance in terms of
the impact they had
on life both
uh it had a huge impact on life because
if if that had not happened you can be
certain that life on earth would be
bacterial only and that took a really
long time too it took two billion years
yeah and it hasn't happened since to the
best of our knowledge so it looks as if
it's genuinely difficult and if you
think about it then from from from just
an informational perspective you think
bacteria have got
they structure their information
differently so a bacterial cell has a
small genome we might have 4 000 genes
in it but a single e coli cell has
access to about 30 000 genes
potentially it's got a kind of
metagenome where other e coli out there
have got different gene sets and they
can switch them around between
themselves
and so you can generate a huge amount of
variation and you know they've got more
an e coli
metagenome is larger than the human
genome
we own 20 000 genes or something
so
and they've had four billion years of
evolution to work out what can i do and
what can't i do with this metagenome and
the answer is you're stuck you're still
bacteria so they have explored
genetic sequence space
far more thoroughly than eukaryotes ever
did because they've had twice as long at
least and they've they've got much
larger populations and they never they
never got around this problem so why
can't they it seems as if you can't
solve it with information alone
so
what's the what's what's the problem the
problem is structure
if if
if cells if the very first cells needed
an electrical charge on their membrane
to grow and in bacteria it's this it's
the outer membrane that surrounds the
cell which is electrically charged
you try and scale that up and you've got
a fundamental design problem you've got
an engineering problem and there are
examples of it on what we see in all
these cases is what's known as extreme
polyploidy which is to say they have
tens of thousands of copies of their
complete genome
which is you know energetically hugely
expensive and you know
you end up with a large bacteria with
no further development
what you need is to incorporate these
electrically charged power pack units
inside with their control units intact
and for them not to conflict so much
with the host cell that it all goes
wrong perhaps it goes wrong more often
than not and then
you change the topology of the cell now
you don't necessarily have any more dna
than a giant bacterium with extreme
polyploidy but what you've got is
an asymmetry you now have a giant
nuclear genome
we're surrounded by lots of subsidiary
energetic genomes that do do all the and
they're the control units that are doing
all the
all the control of energy generation
could this have been done gradually or
does it have to be done
that the power pack has to be all intact
and ready to go and uh it works i mean
it's a kind of step changing the
possibilities of evolution but it
doesn't happen overnight it's going to
still require multiple multiple
generations so it could take you know it
could take millions of years
it could take shorter time there's
another thing i would like to put the
number of steps and try and work out
what's required at each step and we are
trying to do that with sex for example
you can't have a very large genome
unless you have sex at that point so
what are the changes to go from
bacterial recombination to eukaryotic
recombination
what what do you need to do why do we go
from passing around bits of dna as if
it's loose change to fusing cells
together lining up the chromosomes
recombining across the chromosomes and
then going through two rounds of cell
division to produce your gametes all
eukaryotes do it that way
so again you know
why switch what are the drivers here so
there's a lot of there's a lot of time
there's a lot of evolution but as soon
as you've got cells living inside
another cell what you've got is a is a
new design you you've got new potential
that you didn't have before so the
cell living inside another cell that
design
allows for
better storage of information
better use of energy
more delegation like a hierarchical
control of the whole thing and then
and then somehow that leads to ability
to have multi-cell organisms i'm not
sure that you have hierarchical control
necessarily but you you've got a system
where you can you can have a much larger
information storage depot in the nucleus
you can have a much larger genome and
that allows multicellularity yes because
um it allows you
it's it's a funny thing you to to have a
to have a an animal where i have you
know 70 of my genes switched on in my
brain and i have different 50 switched
on in my liver or something you've got
to have all those genes in the egg cell
at the very beginning and you've got to
have a a program of development which
says okay you guys switch off those
genes and switch on those genes and you
guys you do that but all the genes are
there at the beginning that means you've
got to have a lot of genes in one cell
and you've got to be able to maintain
them and the problem with bacteria is
they don't get close to having enough
genes in one cell so they would if you
were to try and make a multicellular
organism from bacteria you bring
different types of bacteria together and
hope they'll cooperate and the reality
is they don't that's really really tough
to do yeah coming into it we know they
don't because they're it doesn't exist
we have the data as far as we know i'm
sure there's a few like special ones and
they did off quickly
i'd love to know some of the most fun
things bacteria have done since
oh there's a i mean they can do some
pretty funky things and this is big this
is broad brush stroke that i'm talking
about
you